VINCE: Hey, I've Vince.
JOHNNY: I'm Johnny.
We're the co-founders of
Social Talent here in Dublin.
VINCE: We actually met in the
Cayman Islands in an Irish bar,
as one does.
And Johnny made a proposition
that I would make millions
from setting up a
recruitment agency.
JOHNNY: Within six months
we'd burned all our money.
We had young kids.
And we said, you know what?
Maybe there's a
business in teaching
people a new way of recruiting.
VINCE: Everything that we
did was quite different.
JOHNNY: Each user
on our platform
gets access to a gamified
learning platform with lots
of content and best practices,
short microlearning videos,
tips on how to use
social media tools, web
tools, different ways
to be more productive.
It's like Netflix for HR
recruiting professionals.
VINCE: Actually, you can
scrap the rest of it.
That's the answer.
JOHNNY: So one day I get a call
from one of our team saying,
Johnny, what you
need this money for?
What do you mean, what
do I need this money for?
She sends me a copy of
an e-mail I apparently
had sent her, saying I
needed her to send me funds.
Then two minutes later,
I got another e-mail
from somebody else, a customer,
saying what's this all about?
I'm the CEO of the
company, and my mail
is used to go to lots of people.
And this was a disaster.
I go down to one of
my colleagues to say,
we need to fix
this, this is crazy.
How do we do it?
Within a few minutes, she got
in contact with our Google team,
and within a few hours,
we had gotten a code
from the guys in support.
And all of a sudden, the
whole thing was resolved.
I didn't expect as
a small business
that we'd get that support.
It was a huge surprise, a huge
comfort to me to get that.
The reputational damage of
that could have been massive.
It just takes one
or two customers
to believe that was us.
For Google to come and help us
like that within a few hours--
that's priceless.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
VINCE: I would like say
that I do get e-mails
from Johnny asking for money.
And I don't believe
they're spoofs.
And, try as I
might, I don't think
Google will be able to help me.